hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american superhero crime and drama
movie called sleight
the story will focus on a young street
magician named beau wolf
by day beau performs magic tricks all
over los angeles with his specialty as
being able to control anything metal
even floated in the air
at one time there is a young woman who
was amazed by his magic tricks
because of this beau manages to get
acquainted with the woman learning her
name which is holly when she asks how he
could do the trick bo just remains
silent because a magician always keeps
his secret based on the magician's
ethics he knows and also never does the
same trick over and over again
meanwhile it turns out that beau has to
take care of his little sister tina
sadly their parents passed away a few
years ago
this leaves beau having to do illegal
activities to keep a roof over their
heads
strangely he apparently did the trick
not using an ordinary tool but by
building an electromagnet into his arm
with the negative electrode of the
battery running to his thumb and the
positive electrode running to his
fingers he first developed the
electromagnet in high school for a
science project which earned him an
engineering scholarship but he had to
turn it down in order to take care of
tina after his parents died however
there is a side effect it seems like he
has to clean his pus that appears every
time
he also has to replace the battery with
a new one
by night he does not have the life of a
normal teenager he is forced to sell
drugs overnight to pay the bills it is
his main source of income every day with
his many base clients he even almost
gets caught by the police when he
finishes selling the drugs but
fortunately he still has not been caught
until now when he checks the money he
got from his magic tricks he finds
holly's phone number on a piece of paper
since long ago he works with his
supplier named angelo who is usually
nice to him
beau is ordered by him to investigate a
new kingpin who comes in and starts
selling drugs for cheaper on their turf
after that beau immediately comes to a
club managed by bo's friend luna where
the new kingpin has his dealers selling
the drugs there he pretends to ask one
of the dealers for drugs and he manages
to get the dealer's cell phone using his
pickpocketing skills as a magician he
immediately looks up his call history
and finds out that his supplier's name
is maurice
the next day beau decides to date holly
thanks to the phone number that he found
last night after they chat for a while
he receives a call from angelo telling
him to come to their base
it turns out that angelo has found where
maurice lives currently they plan to
invade maurice's house on the other hand
beau is given a gun for self-defense
later although he is reluctant to get
involved in this plan at first because
he is basically the type of person who
does not like violence
arriving there they directly catch
maurice including his men
at first they offer cooperation instead
of being hostile as they are now but
because one of maurice's men
underestimates him angelo is annoyed and
immediately hits him as he tells them to
think about his offer carefully
the next morning beau does his magic as
usual which makes the people around him
even more amazed while he is having
dinner together with holly and tina
suddenly angelo and his men come to his
house and ask him to go to maurice's
house again right now because he does
not hit angelo's earlier offer luckily
there are holly and his neighbor georgie
to watch his little sister for the night
a few moments later the group manages to
kidnap maurice while he is walking with
his girlfriend after that an angry
angelo orders beau to chop off one of
maurice's hands
although initially reluctant in the end
he cannot do anything but obey the order
because angelo threatens to harm his
family including holly the person who he
loves most
thus maurice screams in pain very
hysterically as bo leaves the place
unable to stand his own actions just now
thanks to his bravery angelo gives him a
lot of drugs packages
after showing georgie the drugs he plans
to skim fifteen thousand dollars off the
money he makes from drug dealing so he
and tina can pay off the remaining debt
and leave the town in peace
amazingly beau is able to sell the drugs
completely in five days only so he can
quickly give angela the rest of the
money and asks his permission to leave
the job
one morning after holly and bo sleep
together she asked him what has happened
to his hand
from then on all his secrets are
revealed that he is deeply inspired by
the street magician he saw as a child
he is taught by the magician that a
magician must perform tricks that no one
else can do except himself
with his skill in upgrading his tools he
manages to move or lift objects that are
slightly larger and heavier in size such
as an iron chair that he can move around
a bit
at night he goes to a party that has
been held by angelo everything is going
well until angelo invites beau to go
upstairs and finds out that beau was
cheating on his drug packages
as the result he immediately threatens
to kill beau unless he can come up with
45 000 dollars in one week to pay angela
back as a result bo comes home with a
bruised face
he also tells holly everything he is
dealing with
luckily she continues to support him in
making money she even gives the rest of
her savings to help him
long story short he works really hard by
selling the remaining drugs he has while
playing his tricks to make money even
faster
feeling that he still needs more money
he decides to steal the last nine
thousand dollars from luna just in the
right time luna invites him up to the
main office where her safe deposit box
is located beau uses the opportunity to
watch her unlock the safe deposit box
studying the codes when they want to
leave the office he pickpockets the
office keys from her and then pretends
to go to the toilet for a while as luna
walks out first
however he moves the security camera
using his power so he can return back to
the office unnoticed then stealing the
money from the safe deposit box he also
manages to hide after a guard suddenly
enters the office to take things there
afterwards he has a final drink with
luna feeling guilty for stealing from
her but relieved he was out of his
predicament alive
after drinking with her maurice's gang
unexpectedly is at the club at the same
time
when they spot him they managed to knock
him out handcuff him and eventually put
him in the trunk of a car
fortunately he manages to escape by
using his electromagnet to lift the
latches on the handcuffs and trunk
nevertheless maurice has stolen all of
his money in the process
at midnight bowen and his little sister
choose to live at their neighbor's house
as angelo and his men suddenly ran
sackbo's house to collect the money he
asked for previously the following day
beau tells his sister to go back to
school because he thinks that the
situation is already conducive but it
turns out that angelo has told his men
to kidnap tina he finds out when angelo
threatens him again through the phone
call
from that moment beau has no choice but
to hand over the money he doesn't have
as soon as possible when he gets home he
suddenly remembers his old high school
science teacher he then decides to go to
his teacher's house and gets back in
touch with him to get more power to his
electromagnet
therefore the teacher has an idea to add
a feedback oscillator based on his
knowledge they finally managed to
upgrade the electromagnet but he warns
both it may cause the wires in his arm
to overheat
since then those powers have reached the
full potential just like magneto in the
x-men movies
when he feels he is ready he comes to
angelo's house with holly and tells her
to wait outside he then goes inside with
the supplemented electromagnet to find
out where tina is he immediately rips
out one of his former co-workers gold
teeth causing him to bleed he also hits
the other man with his own aluminium bat
and sends it flying into the wall
not long after angelo comes up to shoot
him straight away but what happens next
is that he stops the bullets and causes
the lights to flicker
he then drops the bullets to the floor
and picks one up slowly burrowing it
into angelo's forehead to force him to
divulge tina's whereabouts after angelo
tells beau that she is with his aunt he
releases the bullet from angelo's
forehead and gives him fifteen thousand
dollars before leaving angrily
soon he instantaneously picks up tina
who is not far from there with his arm
burned in the end he chooses to start a
new life peacefully with holly and his
little sister in san diego as they are
getting accustomed to their life beau is
still doing street magic with his new
trick and entertaining the people around
for his main job as his arm has now
completely healed
lastly holly is startled by all the
lights in the house suddenly flickering
by themselves
she then walks into the bathroom to
check on bo looks like he is developing
a new trick from his electromagnet that
might just make him a superhero in the
town
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching